la viande cellulaire avoue avoir ses
limites l'intérêt pour la protéine
végétale ne se dément pas il fait naître
de nouvelles vocations d'entrepreneurs
en particulier chez les millionarios
pendant ce temps dans l'industrie bovine
certains éleveurs se met au diapason des
nouvelles tendances et changent leur
façon de faire
[Musique]
l'institution est prestigieuse célèbre
pour son engagement social et son
activisme étudiants l'université de la
californie à berkeley a aussi une longue
tradition entrepreneuriale et
l'innovation est toujours au coeur de
son mandat
ces étudiants ont la chance de suivre le
tout premier programme au monde
spécialisée dans le développement des
substituts de viande à la mi décembre
le moment est venu pour eux de présenter
leur travail de fin de session
plusieurs compagnies cherchent à
développer des viandes de culture le
poulet le boeuf le porc
ces jeunes rêvent tous de devenir des
entrepreneurs spécialisés dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire 2.0 ils ont
tout pour mission de développer des
projets d'affaires en lien avec la
protéine végétale
il faut voir comment tirer profit de
l'engouement pour la protéine végétale
leurs présentations sont évalués par un
panel d'experts formé de professeurs et
de représentants de l'industrie agro
alimentaire
on propose un prix de détail de 5 $ 75
pour 4 à 6 personnes
cette équipe par exemple a développé un
concept de mai surgelés à base de
protéines végétales dont l'emballage est
entièrement recyclable
le contexte social et unique ici nos
étudiants se sentent réellement
concernés au delà de leur diplôme ils
veulent contribuer au bien être de la
société
on voit le monde autrement nos
consciences se développe encore
récemment on tentait de dompter la
nature
l'opération séduction est terminée
le jury se retire pour délibérer dans
l'auditorium les étudiants attendent de
longues minutes il ya de la tension dans
l'air les juges arrive enfin
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe gagnante a charmé les juges
avec une sauce à base de lentilles
inspiré du moyen-orient du coup elle se
qualifie pour une compétition de plus
grande envergure qui se scindera devant
des investisseurs importants pour ces
jeunes eux mêmes au coeur des nouvelles
tendances alimentaires les protéines
alternative représente la voie de
l'avenir et mola mola de plus en plus de
gens sont également conscients de
l'impact environnemental de la viande et
il met le temps et l'effort nécessaire
pour apprêter des plats végétariens
[Musique]
ricardo san martin
nos guides un peu plus loin sur le
campus de l'université dans les
laboratoires de recherche de stagiaire
postdoctoral met la touche finale à un
substitut de poulet on devait trouver
une solution à la texture sèche et
substituts de bien en deçà a si bien
fonctionné qu'avec l'aide de
l'université on devrait bientôt lancer
notre propre entreprise
c'est la multinationale nestlé qui leur
a donné ce mandat leurs longues heures
de travail seront récompensés les jeunes
chercheuses vont bientôt sortir de
l'anonymat du laboratoire
on part six mois en suisse collaborer
avec nestlé
grâce à son incubateur d'entreprises on
espère arriver à produire à grande
échelle et faire des tests sur le marché
reviendra ensuite aux etats-unis nancy
officiellement notre produit
ce produit s'ajoutera donc à la liste
grandissante des substituts de viande
qui se retrouvent dans les paniers
d'épicerie
car l'empreinte carbone des aliments
dicte de plus en plus les achats des
consommateurs et à ce chapitre
l'élevage a mauvaise presse
selon l'organisation pour l'alimentation
et l'agriculture des nations unies
le secteur de l'élevage est responsable
de 14 et demi pour cent des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et de 63% de la
déforestation en amazonie à eux seuls le
boeuf de boucherie et les bovins
laitiers produisent les deux tiers des
émissions de ge s de l'élevage
e
au pays c'est en alberta que se trouve
le plus important cheptel bovin le
bétail est souvent élevé dans de grandes
fermes intensive et n'aurait avec du
maïs et des céréales ce type d'élevage
consomment beaucoup d'eau et aimé de
grandes quantités de gaz à effet de
serre du méthane notamment
[Musique]
c'est les abattages demeure relativement
stable au canada l'industrie bovine sent
le vent tourner et commence à changer
ses pratiques
aujourd'hui l'accumulation de ces
signaux l'aude engouement pour la
protéine végétale en quelque sorte
deviennent aussi secouer un peu
l'industrie puis lui faire faire un peu
de recul pour peut-être regarder
l'ensemble de ce qu'elle fait comment
elle produit et faire un pas de plus en
fait voilà une transformation et
l'adoption de bonnes pratiques
environnementales notamment
[Musique]
c'est ce qui se passe dans les
contreforts du sud de la province sur un
tronçon de ce qu'on appelle la route des
cowboys ici comme ailleurs au pays
ce point qu'une de nouvelles générations
d'éleveurs je suis ravi de voir les
consommateurs se préoccuper de ce qu'il
marche on aime offrir le produit à
valeur ajoutée
[Musique]
ben kembo a pris la relève de la ferme
familiale en 2013 avec comme principal
objectif de pratiquer une agriculture
plus respectueuse de l'environnement
avec ao toutes les industries sont
surveillés sur le plan environnemental
et c'est très bien
on doit se surpasser selon lui les
éleveurs bovins doivent tendre vers un
modèle de production dont l'empreinte
carbone se compare avantageusement à
celle des légumineuses
ils pratiquent donc l'élevage en
pâturage mobile une méthode s'inspirant
des troupeaux de bisons qui occupaient
les prairies autrefois et qui restaure
la fertilité des sols
pour se nourrir l'hiver les bêtes kruse
dans la neige comme des bisons
ils mangent les hommes qui se cache en
dessous groupe de producteurs bovins est
semblable à celui de gestionnaires de
réserves fauniques
je gère la faune de la sphère bnq mbow
déplace le bétail de parcelle en
parcelle pratiquement tous les jours les
bêtes se nourrissent berne les
déjections et litiges des végétaux sont
piétinés et enterrée par les animaux
elle forme une couche riche en matière
organique dans laquelle les herbes
repousse facilement les plantes captent
par photosynthèse le gaz carbonique de
l'atmosphère la terre n'étant pas
retourner le carbone et séquestrée dans
le sol
et les bovins eux reviennent manger dans
la parcelle deux trois mois plus tard ce
cycle naturel permet d'atténuer les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
responsable des changements climatiques
selon l'éleveur séquestre environ 30
tonnes de carbone à la bourre une ferme
de billag ses 30000 tonnes de carbone
qui sont séquestrés dans le sol de
manière sûre et durable
ce mode d'élevage répond aux besoins de
certains consommateurs soucieux de
réduire leur empreinte environnementale
est préoccupé par le bien-être animal
je ne crois pas que l'engouement pour la
protéine végétale nuise à l'industrie
bovine
[Musique]
l'optimisme de benken beau c'est
notamment au fait que la consommation
mondiale de viande progresse en raison
de sa popularité croissante dans les
pays en voie de développement
il est clair cependant que les
producteurs bovins ont intérêt à
s'inspirer de la filière légumineuses
dont l'empreinte carbone est plus
enviable et les producteurs de
légumineuses de l'ouest refuse d'opposer
la protéine végétale à la protéine
animale
on n'est pas en guerre dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire on doit tous réduire
notre empreinte environnementale
que ce soit le boeuf ou qu'on peut faire
partir de solutions pour être capable
d'aider la planète puisse pense pas que
c'est une tendance qui vaut y voit
s'essouffler
[Musique]
notre relation à la nourriture change
nous sommes de plus en plus conscients
de l'impact de nos choix alimentaires
sur l'environnement et la santé de la
planète
nous sommes déjà trop nombreux
la population augmente sans cesse ya ce
coup mais les ressources de la planète
ne sont pas illimités hors essence il
faut absolument gérer ses ressources
plus efficacement se préoccuper de notre
empreinte environnementale et du
bien-être animal
il faut que ça change aliments
[Musique]